one of the things that's probably the
most important aspect of game theory is
to be allocentric so ego self and a
Louis other and you have to understand
the other person's perspective now the
problem is that when you put yourself in
somebody else's shoes the normal thing
to do is to put yourself in issues as
opposed to how they will react in their
shoes because they may disagree with me
they may have different information
different preferences and it's not what
I would do in Saddam Hussein shoes it's
what he would do in his shoes and I
probably disagree with him on that point
but that's not what game theory tells
you if you have to think about what the
dear leader will do it's not what a
quote western or profit maximizing
person will do it's what is that
person's objective and we often say the
other side is irrational because they're
not doing what we would have done
actually it's us who's irrational we're
not really thinking about what's driving
and motivating the other side
I see fit where people are focused on
now is really the end gaming what games
theory tells you to do is look forward
and reason backward and understand where
you want to end up and then work
backwards from there now one of the
things that often helps people
appreciate that is to actually see the
end point so if various factions they
are appreciate that there is a deadline
for doing something well that gives them
an incentive to say oh my god if we
don't reach this outcome by this amount
of time there's going to be a problem as
opposed to know this that if current
status quo can keep on going and so of
course the consequence is well what
happens if they fail and then you have
sort of the failed state and can they
actually get to any outcome by 18 months
or whatever time frame is provided but
what we tend to do is literally do each
step at the time what looks best and and
the best example of this was really the
failed policy of our defense secretary
who didn't plan about what he would do
after he won as opposed to starting with
okay if I win what would I want to do if
I'm not succeeding what would I want to
do and play out each of those steps and
counter steps and then work backwards to
the present and so we need to do the
exact same thing now what do we do if we
leave and it does blow up does that mean
that we're how do we then come back what
is the deadline to and that to me is of
course the the basics of strategy but
unfortunately it hasn't always been done
jack
I'd like to literally see thee how they
imagine playing out both scenarios and
if you're the end point and if there is
no end point okay we know what this is
today but i don't think that actually is
sustainable and so you know i think it
was the line of a herb Steinman says
that which is a sustainable won't keep
on going on forever and and so just
because something is working right now
whether it be the surge or something
else does it mean that it's the long run
answer and that to me so one side has
given a perspective which may not work
but at least it's a chain of strategy
the other is saying well we're just
going to keep on doing what seems to be
okay at the time
d